logan allen on the mound buxton set to
go
and the opening pitch is a swing of the
ground ball left side sliding stop made
by rosario long throw no shot so bucks
buxton swings at the first pitch and
rips a ground ball in the hole at short
ahmed rosario did everything right but
bucks and speed no chance
here is polanco on track for a 100 rbi
season as well the ball hit hard into
the left field corner buxton oh what a
great play by mercado in left field and
buxton will go to third on a
presumed double
by jorge polanco 30 doubles on the year
now for polanco and that'll bring up ref
snyder
this one slice to right field down for a
hit
buxton will score
and polanco right behind him and just a
handful of pitches into the game the
twins have a couple of runs again
against logan allen
some questionable pitches from logan
allen this is a little breaking ball
that ref snyder doesn't try to pull he
just keeps his head down goes right back
through the ball
puts it in a wonderful spot and bailey
ober on the mound for the 17th time
won't be a full start he will piggyback
with michael pineda tonight
got him looking
what was the phrase you said at or near
the outside
at or near the outside two nothing
minnesota ober's pitch swung on drilled
into right center of base it
second hit for the indians and in
back-to-back innings the lead-off fan is
aboard
check swaying and a foul i think
i think it hit the bat
miller is going to toss the bat away
like he's going to get first base
clearly at the knob of the bat and the
twins aren't challenging it you're right
if that had hit his pinky finger he'd be
doubled over in pain calling him back
home
two and two
it's a ground ball
and a double play
funny how that works sometimes
and the one two swinging a miss and down
he goes that's a change-up
and johnson strikes out so ober sees the
minimum in a scoreless second one down
base is empty polanco doubled and scored
also when ref snyder's hit
polanco to left field and deep beckett
goes deep it goes bleacher shot and gone
polanco from the right side hits his
27th home run three-nothing twins
terrific swing there went up
looking fastball this time and got it in
a really good spot to take a home run
swinging it jose ramirez will lead off
the floor
he's going to take that base hit
i'll tell you what he laid down a
beautiful bun you get your lead off man
aboard for the third straight inning no
i'm sorry three out of four out of four
lead off base runner now with friend
male reyes stepping in
fred meal
high and deep and
going to souvenir city
[Applause]
the franimal gets the indians on the
board here in the fourth inning
his 27th home run of the year
and he is getting hot
yes he is
he hung him a slider and he destroyed it
so i mean that bunt really paid off for
ramirez
over knew it was gone as soon as he
threw that pitch i think
let's flip that bat away take the stroll
his 27th homer and the indians are on
the board and cut it to a one-run ball
game now
[Music]
right field deep down the line
up the wall
miller hurrying towards second good
throw but he's in there safely
with a one-out double
line to hasta dio
and now throw across the third and they
got him cenotes arm pays off
and ostidio
got an assist and a put out on one of
the weirdest double plays you'll ever
see
look the runner back or at least he
thought he did threw to first and then
had to get back to the bag terrific play
there but pick a short hop and then
another terrific play
with ceno coming firing off of first
base he ran off the field so fast his
hat came
top of the lineup byron buxton steps in
buxton lifting it high deep left center
field going back is mercado and that
ball is gone a home run
buxton's first since his return to the
lineup his 11th of the year
and it's 4-2 minnesota
that's got to feel good yesterday danny
had the two hits first multi-game and
now backs it up with two more tonight
byron now against cleveland forgets his
naland but against cleveland this season
a small sample with the injuries but
he has now nine hits and 12 at bats
there's a line drive center field that's
going to land for a base hit there you
go one out single so he's on with a
runner at first base
and rooker and jeffers ground ball right
side that's a base hit
and rooker is going to advance to second
so
first pitch swinging for jeffers going
the other way
not a swing we're used to seeing from
ryan jeffers but i but i like it
drops the head on it it's like i don't
care where this ball goes i'm just going
to try to hit it hard somewhere and
got himself a base hit gonna get luis
our eyes off the bench
and a ground ball through the hole to
left
rooker will be waved around third and he
will score
with three straight singles and a pinch
hit single
by louis said eyes
he should contend
i would think
for a batting title sometime
not done yet
shooting for 30 home runs and 100 rbis
that's the left field toward the corner
and off the base of the wall he has
another extra base hit
four on the night including three
doubles
just a beautiful swing good fastball
from garza up and out over the plate
goes right with it
very strong with a bat in his hand very
quick big end of the bat at the ball or
hey polanco and that allows him to
drive the ball all over the field now
the 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss elevated fastball
garcia get out of it
lead off double does no damage
full count
and
the twins get a wonderful pitching
performance from four different pitchers
to close down a 5-2 win